for today's classic interview we're
going back to March of 2013 when I
interviewed Michael Bishop who is a
climate or was a climate change denier
who actually had land taken for the
Keystone XL pipeline the newsworthiness
of this story and revisiting it struck
me when I read that just a few days ago
a federal judge temporarily blocked the
Keystone XL pipeline on the basis that
the Trump administration ignored
inconvenient facts related to climate
change in there pushing forward of the
Keystone XL pipeline and I thought back
to my conversation with Michael Bishop
also someone who denied climate change
and changed his tune when he actually
had to face it himself as the government
seized land so let's go back to my
conversation with Michael Bishop from
March of 2013 joining me is Michael
Bishop Michael is a retired chemist and
a landowner farm owner in Texas back in
2008 Michael received a letter from
TransCanada saying that his property has
been selected as a potential route for
the Keystone XL pipeline Michael talked
to us first thank you for being here by
the way talk to us first about that
first letter you got from TransCanada
what it said and what happened David the
first letter we got basically not very
explicit you said that we were a
potential site there
crude oil pipeline so when you got that
letter did you respond did people just
kind of show up at your property what
was the next thing that happened they
threatened to put me in jail and
basically on my own property and that
that irritated the devil out of me so I
I confronted them back and told them if
they didn't get off my property they
were gonna be some serious health issues
with their crews and somebody was going
to jail
and it was not gonna be me so I ran them
off my property and I didn't hear
anything for about six months to a year
after that so when you when you finally
had a meeting with some of the
representatives from TransCanada who
wanted
the Keystone pipeline through your
property you actually said hey you know
you could run this through the western
part of my property
I wouldn't charge you anything for that
just that would be where I would prefer
you run this and you were told basically
you can't tell us where to run the
pipeline that's that's very that's very
correct that the situation was was if
when I was under the impression at the
time that it was a crude oil pipeline
realized in Texas law and realizing that
I would have been beating my head
against the wall went ahead and said
look the route you want to take is
inappropriate it's not acceptable it's
gonna impact myself and my neighbors
I've got a solution for you there is a
misting right away with three pipelines
on it one is a small natural gas
pipeline the other is a Sunoco crude oil
pipeline I'm about a 24 inch line the
other is an abandoned had been abandoned
for nearly 30 years it was a BP Amoco
crude oil line all they had to do was
come in a straight line on the western
edge of my property follow the route
that was an existing oil route right
away that was already there
and in the end the problem would have
been solved and I told them in I said I
do not want your money I don't like you
I don't like your company I will give
you the land just stay away from where I
live we shook hands we had a meeting we
shook hands they agreed to it but the
man told me and no Sun no uncertain
terms they they cannot be told by any
regulatory agency or land on earth where
they can put their line they can put
their line directly under your house and
under Texas law they have to they have
to pay for the house to be moved well
that just gives them unlimited authority
and I'm opposed to that hey Michael is
it common in Texas to have three
pipelines going through your property as
it is and then I mean is these common
situations where people have so much
stuff going through their properties oh
absolutely you're you're looking at a
state that it's just there's millions of
miles of pipelines ladyness in this
state and
and basically it's their every word you
can't go three or four hundred feet not
find a pipeline somewhere so yeah it's
very common as it stands right now
what's the latest offer because I know
there have been a number of
back-and-forth sand discussions with
TransCanada about the Keystone XL
pipeline going through your property
what's the latest offer that you have on
the table or where do things stand right
now the latest off we've settled we
settled in a mediation hearing but that
settlement as I've contended in my
lawsuits was done under coercion and
extreme duress and I can prove that
beyond a shadow of a doubt it's just
it's ridiculous and TransCanada even
though I've settled I've gone back to
court and filed a fraud lawsuit I filed
a suit in Travis County with the state
capital Austin Texas against the
Railroad Commission which is the
permitting agency and I'm I'm halfway
through preparing my suit against the
railroad I mean the Army Corps of
Engineers
so are there is work being done on your
property right now the work is just
completed although the property has not
been restored as as they agree to and
they're originals in the original
settlement or cording to the law they
have not they have not restored the
property and in all honesty the damage
is irreparable they will never be able
to restore the property to its original
okay so that's what I want to focus on
what's been done what damage has been
done
I've got it I've got two creeks going
through my property and these creature
net are a springfed natural creeks and
the problem is they have muddied those
creeks at the point they've destroyed
the vegetation the wildlife they have
destroyed the banks of the creek they
came in with their giant excavators and
track codes and they they leveled and
leveled the creek the bank of the creek
down to the point where it will never be
restored to its natural condition never
hey I'm curious Michael what before this
incident right what were your politics
like in other words were you already
what was your view on oil and drilling
has this changed it or it has it just so
happened that they came across somebody
who was against this stuff to begin with
look I've spent a large amount of my
years in in the petrochemical industry I
was a firefighter/paramedic I worked as
a lab technician and eventually as a
chemist and I was raised on the ship
channel in Houston
I have no I'm not I have no beef with
oil oil is not the problem this is not
crude oil as my lawsuit or content or a
difference here the problem is and you
know we're going back to your question
I'm I'm an ultraconservative basically I
voted Republican since Richard Nixon
sucked in the marine corps in the 60s
but now I am a full-blood libertarian so
and basically this is a about I used to
belong to a group of scientists that
believe that this this climate change
claim was a fabrication it was an
economic manipulation I have since
changed my views on that I am now a
member of the American Union of
Concerned Scientists fascinating and and
so I'm guessing that you're okay you
know this you your story was pitched to
me by a pretty progressive you know
liberal organization you see you're okay
on those issues working with progressive
groups I would take it absolutely listen
here's the thing climate change is not a
fantasy this is a real event we're in
we're in serious trouble in this country
and then people like me had to wake up a
hard way and say no wait a minute I'm a
very I'm an analytical chemist I have to
stop and I have to look at the facts I
have to assess those facts and I think
the evidence is overwhelming at this
point that we we have adjust our thought
process but going back to a local
personal issue this is a matter of
eminent domain and sovereignty of
American citizens you're talking about a
foreign private corporation stealing
American land for private personal gain
and I'm sick and tired of my co-workers
sitting here telling me that
oh this is good it's going to lower the
price of gasoline it's going to give us
security for America and its baloney
you're talking about a foreign private
corporation located in Canada it's
bringing down a toxic corrosive material
that is not crude oil by any definition
federal or state and this and taking it
to another foreign private corporation
that corporation is motiva one of them
is motiva motiva is a joint venture
between Royal Dutch Shell and Saudi
Arabia refining that is a private
economic gain and Texas law they are
violating Texas law the Constitution
clearly states that in our state your
property can only be taken for public
use not for private economic day so I'm
fighting them and we're gonna win and
they're gonna have to dig the damn line
up period all right we've been speaking
with Michael Bishop from Texas Michael
really great to hear your story I'm
sorry that this is the reality of the
situation but we're gonna keep following
it and we'll definitely have you back
David thank you for having me I
appreciate